hey hey hey we are back what do you got
for me
I'm just trying to get my volume right
oh nice nice nice people watching on
YouTube look at all the wood in here how
much wood could a woodchuck chuck if a
wood took over which I could chuck wood
chuck could okay like that
do we have temporary art in here right
now I'm not Emperor Lee getting high
from the lacquer on the wood dude I mean
I'm getting late oh crap if we get a
little loopy 45 minutes in we're good
check it out on YouTube we haven't seen
on the Bleacher Report channel vacations
are in the book hello and you know what
that means
our focus has squarely set on the
football Yellowstone was cool yellow the
yellow stoners had a good time at yep
phil simms is their cool it was great
it's great I mean it was cool just to do
a different type of trip than just going
to the beach in the ocean and you got
super close to a bear bears Cubs bison
when you got close to the bear did you
realize it could totally beat a lion
there's a black bear and I felt like I
could kick the [ __ ] out of that bear so
no but it was protecting its calm yes
you're telling me that you sized up the
bear you're at Yellowstone everyone's
like there's a bad man you ate you went
okay my mom was getting nervous that my
kids were getting a little close and the
bear was a hundred pounds roughly is
what our torget black bear is like
they've not huge right Grizzlies is the
right Grizzlies of a 100 pound black
bear is basically what he said but he's
like you got to remember if it's a
hundred pound black bear because their
muscle mass is different that it's
basically gonna be like a 200 pound
person oh so I was watching this mama
cup she was real cute but my mom started
getting paranoid and I was like well if
this thing makes a dash across the
street and goes up there my kids I'm
gonna run and lower my shoulder I'm
gonna see what happens so you're yes
you're not enjoying nature you're
getting ready and doing other things
right yes I was worried about stuff like
that I was also worried like when you
got too close to the Bison I was like
damn Beth Lee wants to get up and top
all our drug
we better run in there in a hurry man
yeah yeah it was good man you saw my
face when I came in I mean thank God I'm
personally
look when you get into a pool and you
forget you're like let's just I'm gonna
hang with my girl and we're gonna drink
a little too much just pull too much
when you have the Caribbean right next
to you I just saw that I did the ocean
edge pool too much cool it's amazing I
wouldn't even go in the pool on a trip
like yeah I would be like [ __ ] that pool
I can find a pool anywhere I will never
side really will go out of my way not to
spend two seconds my everything this is
when you live in New York
yeah any body of water like if I'm
walking down 8th Avenue there's a puddle
like the fans missed us to a lot of
people reached out here's a good one
this is from putco fleet he's saying I
gotta be 100% honest with you guys
having just one podcast this week was
the worst thing imaginable I'm sorry how
am I supposed to get through the week
without my two favorite football guys
pumped for tomorrow though forecasts for
the weather is a sunny day with a big
chance of whoa seizes up and that was
big love for Mexico they feel weird like
being out of the not having to do
anything like I yeah i i i still texted
Fenric a bunch but i wasn't checking
like a bunch of the news stuff so I came
back Sunday night and I had like 12
pages of stuff that we had missed yeah
one thing that I think we'll everybody
likes to debate LeBron that's Lee told
me that I don't even like get that
they're like are you LeBron fan and I
was like yes and I know I'm not and I'm
like what I'm like this may it comes to
your island like LeBron I just don't
understand it doesn't make any sense
yeah I don't I'm like totally don't
understand it I'm at the point with
LeBron where I'm like I understand if
he's not your favorite but what's not to
like I don't get yeah I do know one
thing though the Sims and Lefko football
league is officially kicking off I'm
Roger Goodell shout out to Meat Loaf
putting the whole thing together so we
can't the drug test all these people for
our league we're testing you don't have
at least a hundred games of THC in your
urine then you can't so we came on two
weeks ago and said there's five
holy crap we're up to five guys it ended
up 28 leagues
holy cow of 14 people each that's three
hundred and ninety two players will be
joining the SL FL we are now in
conferences The Meat Loaf has put
together all of the rules shouts to you
for doing this it's incredible way to go
Meat Loaf but dude they're so it's gonna
go through 12 weeks then we're gonna
have a tournament and then in the final
week all of the conference winners will
have the highest score wins I was just
telling Josh we're gonna send prize
packs I think to all of the people that
win their conference so if you win one
of your 28 conferences we're gonna send
you some gear cause I think we should
have a show that fell yeah we're gonna
take a look at all these leagues I think
throughout the year we should keep tabs
and I'll tell people it's not butter
smart they are it's not even just going
to be us there is also going to be
someone a H sharer who is going to be
releasing a video weekly updating all of
the leagues right so we have our own
fantasy reporter sharor
but some of the names for the leagues we
have the big [ __ ] conference you have
the say quads conference we have the
mother hen conference the legs and ass
conference and I believe that we are
apart you me and Fenric are splitting a
team in the golden spleen we called in
spleen team yeah and I saw some of the
names someone stole your weed strain
name spleen buster oh gee that's
someone's team name so I need to figure
out our team - I go by sativa sorry
sativa Sims I also kind of went viral
during this off go kind of viral
I got tweeted out by shefter the NFLPA
Jalen Ramsey was like in my tweets right
I just I got really tired of all these
stories that were this is the nightmare
offseason for the NFL Oh Jameis all
LeSean McCoy and I was like I have been
putting together whoa big off seasons
for this entire offseason I know all of
the good things people have been doing
and we're only focusing on like the two
or three negative things so I just
created the hashtag NFL good guys put
together a stream of 20 and it was all
over the place
and it was it was cool because that's
what we do in my opinion that seems left
go podcast we are the players podcast we
do care about showing both sides of
these guys and now I'm getting tweeted
all the time by like NFL players doing
good stuff like I saw Leno the offensive
lineman for the Bears stopped and filled
up like the gas tank somewhere in Travis
Kelce took kids out to go shopping and
then it's just so many there's 3,000
guys in this league it doesn't even
include coaches and all that stuff we
can focus on the negatives but there's
an amazing amount of guys out there
doing great [ __ ] there's not 3000 it's
like 1,500 I think it's 15 oh I think
I'm including like coaches and maybe the
90 plus roster it's actually three
thousands like right I mean you're right
it's three guys out of a thousand or
1500 guys and we're gonna focus on that
and in the offseason even though you
know people like JJ Watt and Malcolm
Jenkins and horses
it's it's it's unanimous it drives me
crazy about the profession I've been
saying it for so long right it drove me
crazy when I was in the locker room
playing because I would go I just it's
wrong the way it's portrayed in the
public a lot of times by the media it's
every locker room I was in if it's it's
okay it's 53 guys damn eight years of 53
guys I'm gonna tell you there was like
four or five bad guys out of those years
where I would just go and they weren't
even that bad but for the most part and
it just I feel like other professions
have a lot more worse guys but it just
never gets talked about I just think
with the NFL the amount of discipline
that these guys have to have to learn
things but also their body they don't
really have time to do that many bad
things don't get me wrong I am NOT
excusing the domestic violence stories
I'm not excusing all of the other
criminal actions and stuff that have
happened however the mass majority it's
impressive very one other thing that has
been upsetting me yeah this is a weird
thing for me to be upset about I'm
getting really tired of seeing people
say man I'm just like I wish football
season would be here and they go quiet
Newsday man I wish football season would
get here if you're listening to one of
these podcasts
that are saying oh gosh can't wait till
football's here then then why would you
listen to them during the season because
I can get you 12 pages of football news
every day there's a million stories so
all these people they're like nah I wish
there was football going on I don't
trust it I'm not listening to those
people during the football season
I'm not ball seasoned so why would I
listen during the season yes I believe
the word you're looking for is we are
very nuanced okay Wow education tell me
that one yes seriously I mean we live it
you and I so I hope people do respect
that and what was the other thing oh did
I don't know if I told you this or not
but I was told I just thought this I get
really excited I was told when pac-man
Jay Jones knocked that dude out right
yeah that the guy broke his leg broke
his neck yes he did yeah falling that's
amazing some of my pac-man's homies
texted me he got he was getting booked
and then he was there with a cast on his
legs and me I didn't see the picture and
I knew he had go to the hospital I
didn't realize really you got punched so
hard in the face collapsed and broke
okay but that was another one that was
like uh the NFL is having a nightmare
offseason like that's not the NFL also I
would say this the Brandon browner thing
yeah the last league he played for was
what the CFO nope it was the flag
football he literally played a night
before that happened was it a favor NFL
player or is it a flag football player I
think the flag football league has a lot
of big issues this officer and what did
Brandon browner what was the last time I
was in the NFL was he in the 16 did he
play for the Saints a little and six he
did right he got picked up and everyone
thought he was gonna be this great guy
we were sitting there going he was his
last year with the Patriots he was like
mr. pass interference and then he went
to the New Orleans Saints and it came
like dr. pass interference I feel like
we've gotten a lot of new people this
offseason and I pledge to you you will
notice the difference between us and
everybody else during the season because
we actually watch the games we actually
give a [ __ ] and Sims can give you stuff
that you will not get anywhere else I
promise you now I need to admit that I
was wrong Odell did not get his contract
by July 25
I have been eliminated along with
hundreds of other people guessing when
he's gonna get it he is going to be
reporting to camp yes good
which just don't do team drills I always
do isolated rumors but yeah I was wrong
July 20th and you're thinking it's still
gonna be July 2005 I'm not I'm thinking
I'm gonna be wrong as well I do yeah I
think it's a contract
I would change it now to like August
28th mm-hmm close I think so I think
it's gonna become listen Sims and left
go faithful let's just keep piling it on
the Giants hey I love the Giants but man
they're wrong in this situation they
need to pay him then I think we should
continue to badger them until they pay
him appropriately appropriately been
very professional this offseason about
as professional as it can get at the
wide receiver position for an NFL
football player who's one of the best
guys in the league and he shut his mouth
shows up to work he's had the perfect
offseason and they need to pay him like
the best receiver in football men to
some other people that were eliminated
July 22nd abdi Adhan said today is my
birthday
Odell getting a contract would be a
great present sorry LaVista who else got
eliminated fashion faux pas Marc Hancock
was eliminated our can cot
Patrick Garvey wrote Chris and Adam on
my birth parents he was eliminated so
yeah sorry birth son yeah not today it's
okay it is that time though where we
have been away for a long time big
offseason I want to get right into it
whoa whoa big offseason and the number
one story that I was upset that we
didn't have our podcast to get back and
do was the Jimmy G Chiara Mia story well
it happened but I'm Thursday so I'm
saying I was in Anguilla I'm on the
beach and I get a bleach report alert
Jimmy G seen on date with porn star
Chiara me so I'm gonna say this yes I
saw the picture first right I didn't
need to see the name
you knew I'm just gonna say that two
thoughts came to my mind yes whoa big
offseason the second one was
um a little jealous I my second thought
was Jimmy G you're the freakin man yeah
and it was funny I don't think I think
it was full outrage I don't think anyone
was like this is ridiculous like I
didn't I didn't actually see any of that
but I saw a lot of people standing up
for someone that no one was attacking
like I saw a lot of people being like
she's a hard-working person I was like
no one I haven't seen one person working
she's doing her stuff right uh but she
was tracked down first thing I saw well
the first thing I saw is like the video
I saw the name and I was like wait I
think I know that and it was like in a
distance right and I couldn't see and
then I saw like the little picture where
she's actually like picking up her shirt
as she's getting up I mean he's a young
guy it's how do you think the Niners are
taken it's kind of funny I mean you see
Jimmy Garoppolo he's very handsome I
think we all can say that she's very
attractive area tractive but I know
there's people in the football world
they're like I mean he could date a
supermodel why would he date a girl like
this well I could tell you why but I'm
not gonna be too graphic about it right
now
and he's having maybe he's more
attracted to the chiara me who cares
right it doesn't matter he's allowed to
do what he wants in his own free time I
so but what else were you going to share
from the 49ers though oh they're just
they're like what they're still learning
about him as a person like you know they
know about him as a football player and
everything and and not to say that
there's anything bad as a person but
they've only been with them for a few
months and this I can't wait to kind of
hear Kyle's reaction about this and what
he says about it because I know you
really liked Jimmy gee that's a great
dude and I'm sure knowing Kyle will have
a lot of fun with Jimmy Garoppolo
sometime here in the first week like
gonna do something to razz him in front
of the team I'm sure to just be like we
all saw who you went on a date with last
week I just think it shows that Jimmy
G's really adept at watching film he's
all ha ha ha but I will say that Kiara
Mia was found followed down by TMZ said
the date was great so that he was so
respectful and so nice and then added
this
so she touched up he's got a golden
straw sorry it's so hard to not be
appropriate on this one I hope that's
why I got it makes I want to start here
with this I just think it's amazing that
if the 49ers rolled it all makes sense
if the 49ers win at all it's all because
of Chiara me oh yeah that mean we need
to have her on the podcast if they start
to have them winning ways I really think
we do I think what's really interesting
is everyone says if I was gonna be the
starting quarterback of the 49ers with a
hundred million dollar contract at 26
years old and I'm one of the best
looking guys the NFL I'm gonna go on
dates I'm gonna do all this stuff but
then when another guy doesn't like can
you believe that he's actually going on
a date with this girl yeah I just think
it's funny I do too it's uh it's cool I
think props to him I got no I I think a
lot of props to him for just what yeah
how does the locker room react oh I
think the locker room is gonna relieve
like they're gonna love it and have fun
and it's gonna actually humanize him I
think in a lot of ways I think a lot of
men have that kind of fantasy to begin
with it without getting too deep into
this subject right I mean apparently our
president did as well so it's not that
crazy for a quarterback to think this so
it's like not that off the rails I think
a lot of guys gonna have a lot of fun
with this though oh you know they're
gonna who knows there's gonna be some
crude talk for sure our guy Juden Lee
had an article come out about Jimmy G
today yes in which he said that he him
and Brady were intensely competitive and
that they wanted to kill each other Wow
so that came out today I didn't know
that check out that article what do you
think about hearing that well I think
there's truth they're two very
competitive people I do think that I
mean I don't know to what extent they
were competing but I mean Tom and will
get to us I mean Tom's of relentless
worker Tom is he's the ultimate
competitor I mean that's what I love Tom
Brady I know I'd still think he's guilty
of deflategate okay everybody out there
and he is there's really no other way
around it in my eye
but he's still awesome and men there's
so many ways of Tom Brady like I would
want to act like Tom Brady as a
quarterback the way he does even the
video he sent out the other day I know
of him throw out of the dude in the Gulf
go like okay that's cool I mean I don't
know if I'd be making Instagram videos
of myself quite but I do appreciate his
work ethic his attention to detail he is
fearless competitor I can still remember
in 2005 when we end up to New England
and played them in that game the one
thing I took away from that game was I
just remembered walking off the field
and they beat us like 27 to nothing but
I actually played a pretty solid game we
had some team mess ups and I made a few
plays here and there but regardless I
took away from it going ooh this is the
next level of leadership I have to go do
to where he's at what was he doing just
like he was on his team relentlessly
when he got hit
I could hear a [ __ ] the linemen
and saying things and that's where I do
think Brady's greatness and I know you
and I have talked about this a little in
the past you can't quantify the fact
that he's actually like almost an extra
coach an extra field general all the
time he can hold the players accountable
almost of the extent or more than Bill
Belichick when they hear from him
they're like damn I let Tom down I let
him get hit or blindsided like they sure
worse about that than they do have
Belichick was like you're an idiot
don't run a lap so to have that is is
something that goes overlooked I think
with great players like Tom Brady at
times
speaking of leadership like that let's
get to another whoa big offseason
Mitchell true Biscay is emulating Tim
Duncan he said quote fundamental it
doesn't have to be cursing someone it
has to be real that's what the Spurs did
for Tim Duncan this is another bleacher
report piece by Tyler Dunn he said I
don't want to be the guy
cursing everybody out I want them to get
focused on the next play you just talked
about how you loved Brady and how he
would MF everybody right when you hear
that is that good or bad coming out of
Travis Key it's good you got to do your
own style and you got to be your own guy
and I would look at Mitchell too risky
and I could have told you I think before
he got drafted to go he's never gonna
lead like Tom Brady that's not in his
DNA
like deshaun Watson the same thing he's
never gonna mother after anybody it
doesn't mean you can't be a good leader
it is
greatness I think about Brady but you
can still lead other ways and still have
greatness about you too
I mean there's been plenty of
quarterbacks through time who are that
take that quiet approach I'm just gonna
work hard keep my nose down perform on
the field let everybody see my actions
and people will follow from that
standpoint and then I have no problems
with that you you got to do what's
naturally within you you can't have you
ever seen someone really try and be
different I have like you gonna say is
you can always point out the fake
leaders like it's just gonna show it so
come on I don't really want to know if I
I mean there was like you guys know
right now no I can't think of anybody
right now I wish I would have thought
about this longer but you just if you
come off as in genuine as that leader
like guys you got a work Carter but
you're the one that's like not in the
weight room after practice or you don't
ever watch film or your mess up the
calls talked about key shot a lot yeah
well okay but yes certainly I know
you're loving to try to put me with
somebody here trying very hard but just
at some point it's gonna come off to the
locker room that oh this is a fake he's
a Fugazi and he's not a leader and we're
not gonna buy into his crap disingenuous
disingenuous is genuine is that what I
said that you said in genuine oh did I
yeah I disingenuous yes say that all
right I want to do a little another
quick whoa whoa Joe Mixon came in at
2:30 whoa
he's down the 218 whoa how big of a deal
is that almost as big a deal as your
cheeks being red no they're not that red
now it's not that funny uh I actually
I'm not like whoa this is the biggest
thing I've heard offseason but I will
put it into this like frame of mind Joe
Mixon has incredible talent I think you
and I both know that and like him being
a step faster a step quicker he has
incredible ability Joe Mixon is one of
those guys where I say it's whoa
because I would not be shocked if in the
end of this season we go man Joe mix-ins
one of the five best running back to
football I do think he can creep his way
into that discussion with his build his
movements his body makeup everything
about him yeah that offense I think the
way they're gonna ride him yeah he has
special talent so when I hear that I go
oh he he could
a little bit different this year a
little more explosive able to take place
to the house here that s LFL draught Joe
but I think he was compared a lot to
levy on bail coming out levy on lost a
lot of weight to in a second year yes he
did you see similarities there I do see
similarities to their run game I think
actually that this kid is probably a
hair more explosive straight away but I
do think there's very similar ways in
which they run he has a little bit of
that delayed run as well where he comes
up to the line and he kind of waits to
see where he's got to go I do I see a
lot of that similarities in their
side-to-side movement and and really you
know his muscular bill that actually is
more important than less mean more
impressive than levy on bail damn I mean
just when you see him as a person and
what he looks like it is and levy on
bail is extremely impressive doesn't
mean he's gonna be a better football
player obviously but yeah I think Joe
Mixon is one of those guys I'd say watch
out for they were very willing to get
rid of Jeremy hill and all those guys
exactly not even a split and they got
Giovanni Bernard there for the passive
Jewish a question is gonna be offensive
line yes it is because they've been
investing in it and they haven't been
paying no it has not been Danny Dalton
still not the guy but he'll thing AJ
Green makes everybody better does all
right so another whoa big offseason
people are clamoring over Sean mcveigh's
incredible photographic memory did an
interview with Bryant Gumbel in which
Bryant Gumbel kind of mentioned a few
different situations to him and Shawn
McVeigh could rattle it off in the
Internet Sims oh my god he's a genius
he's incredible I can't believe it and
my thought was Sims could do this I
could ask Sims the same situations and
he could do it not just you yeah I think
people that are studying football all
the time I don't think it's that
impressive right I just think people
like myself get overwhelmed by this
first one he said last year week 16
you're playing the Titans I already got
this right to you you got the ball
second eleven at your own 24 24 the
second quarter I everyone had to say
during their run down and he throws a
screen to Todd Gurley to the left side
yes not the see parts and he runs up the
left sideline stops or doesn't stop but
makes a cut to the right and kind of
runs through the end zone somewhere
around the left hash I'm pretty sure I'm
correct with that all right so you you
got that right - so here's the
second moment and I'm gonna stop and
just tell me yeah okay I like Brian you
can hear him yep
third and 51 Robert Phillips meaning the
second quarter Giants got the ball third
and 10 at the 14 yard line where what
happened okay
do you remember what happened what
quarter was it you talked cuz you can't
stop sake came to New York you're
playing the Giants in week 9 yeah 2:40
remaining the second quarter Giants got
the ball third and 10 at the 14 yard
line
and what happened ooh there are 14 this
is I think Eli throws an interception to
Alec Ola tree I want to say but I could
be wrong okay I'm gonna play the clip I
don't remember I don't know either I'm
not sure about the two 40 left in the
second quarter Tremaine Johnson had an
interception so you're right you got the
interception but the guy was wrong I
thought it was a local okay so see this
is what I'm saying I think it's
impressive yes I don't think it's that
impressive miss - what's your own for
contained yes okay alright let's try one
more week five going way back now you're
at home against the Seahawks 56 seconds
left third quarter Rams got the ball
third and 20
Seattle's 25 mmm I believe oh it's
definitely a Jared Cook tips I want to
say it's the bad screen pass Jared Goff
Jared golf tip screen pass gets
intercepted something like that okay
let's I want to say it's something like
let's see damn I'm nervous actually
third and 20 on Seattle's 25 going in
yeah we call the screen and it got
picked good and if anybody thinks I'm
cheating at home I swear and my kids I'm
not and I don't swear my kids unless I'm
I'm swearing on my kids if you want to
follow the Sean McVeigh of sports
broadcasting check out Sims I knew you
were gonna do it I knew it well I
watched that I was like Sims could do
this easily cuz you because to me also
the ones he asked the screen if you're
buying the league and you watch the film
you should stick out in your brain right
dude I knew you're gonna thanks and that
was a big pipe man the Rams would have
won that game if really that didn't
happen there but yeah
I would think most invested me most head
coaches for the most part I'm not gonna
say how many coaches could do that I
think really the play caller coaches
could do it maybe not all the channels
yes I will check right balichek can tell
you like okay let's plays 71 from 1924 I
mean he's unbelievable that's not even
fair but I do think most of those type
of head coaches play callers along with
your quarterbacks can do that and mcvade
those were layups for him I'm sure
McVeigh probably could you could go into
like random third and six that's what I
want why he probably could but Brian
Gumbel is trying to give it something
sexy but he could Rob it oh that was
third and six over the minute that was
incomplete Jarrod made a wrong read and
threw to the guy shouldn't like that's
how awesome he would be right like I
probably wouldn't be able to guess those
I would be if I could coach the team and
was the offensive coordinator sure sure
sure yes that that's what a lot of these
guys brains work like and I think that's
what makes them so great at calling
plays during the games and makes them
unbelievable at you know calling
audibles whether it's a quarterback or
the offensive coordinator during games
because they can see little clues and go
ooh that reminds me of that play I
watched on film three weeks ago they
when he does that they bring that bullet
so I'm gonna start calling this play and
though those are the little things that
the great coaches can do have you ever
been around a great coach that had a bad
memory I know I know they all have great
memories they really wish Jeff Fisher's
members Jeff Fisher's memories
phenomenal really yeah it is like I
don't think he's the type of guy again
that's gonna be able to be an
encyclopedia that's again he would fall
into the list of the next group of guys
where you know he's gonna be able to
tell you a lot about a game but he might
not be able to call out every certain
play because I truly is managing the
game Jeff Fisher was an awesome manager
of the game right he did things that I
was like ooh that is really a few steps
ahead he's higher steps ahead he's
thinking about oh I might he had the
guys in the repay booth he'd be like
show the replay in the big scoring so I
can get it Jeff Fisher did things like
we're about Gruden girl Gruden would be
like McVeigh he wouldn't without a doubt
he'd be able to rattle it off in two
seconds he this is funny because I
remember when
LeBron was in the finals and he was like
replaying one of the plate like one of
the possessions in his head and
everybody was like oh that's so
impressive and I heard a few MBA players
go we can all do that yeah yeah like
that's something we could all do I
figured this was something just like I
think all the good veteran players
especially in the NBA yeah I mean it
goes into the whole comment of what like
we always talked about with like sports
like when people were was like the game
slowing down for him right like I bet
you there's some rookie quarterbacks
this year where they can't remember
plays they're like am I kidding remember
because the game was a world win to them
first year they're just like damn can I
get the play out of the huddle okay I
got the huddle let me just figure out
what was this play again as they're
walking in the line of scrimmage where
you have the guys like you know the
Mathieu staffers that Drew Brees all of
them we're comfort in their zone the
game is so slow it's like it's another
game on a Sunday this is great yeah and
they the game is so slow to where they
can recall it all Payton was the same
way yeah I mean like I told you I
literally feel like I could see things
on the field that I would not be able to
see in everyday life because your senses
are so alert to you know when people are
trying to tear your head off that are a
lot bigger than you and you have 70,000
fans the [ __ ] you can hear and see it's
like a survival mechanism right we had
the brain guy come in here talk there's
a little bit same thing like I remember
dropping back to pass and being like man
he's 30 yards away and he's wearing like
a face mask that's got a lot of stuff on
it but I can see his eyes and like where
he's looking at his body might be
pointing to the left but it's nicely the
right your running back dropping back
and I'd be like in good Nick why didn't
you throw that guy out I was like I'm
just telling you all his bright lights
were on the guy you wanted me to throw
to he was just waiting for me to do that
and those are the little things you
start to go oh I'm getting comfortable
like I'm like really noticing [ __ ] that
I never noticed before that's when I
always think of the Ray Lewis quote
where he's like your brain reaches a
speed oh that's so fast right right when
your body can't be at that speed yeah
yeah right when the game is like I could
do whatever I want right legs go right
he's like Zach Thomas like we talked
about ray played ray once in my life and
he definitely called eight to ten run
plays spot-on knew where we were running
and I was just like here you go here's
speaking of Ravens last whoa big
offseason the battle continues between
Flacco and Lamar Jackson can I say this
yeah I thought about you so many times
this week and yellow some really weird
Wyoming it's alright that's okay
because they have Ravens there and it's
just like fire Raven I just love it but
the R sound that we have for our Raven
board whatever ash is not it's so
spot-on and every time my family saw me
like giggle a few times because I always
thought about you okay Lamar Jackson
article came out yesterday or a quote
from RT morning wig quote he's way ahead
of the curve now but I went and I looked
into the article because we take this
one line and we make it the whole piece
and no one reads anything anymore and
the rest was as far as his accuracy and
all that he's really really worked hard
and you can see on the practice field
it's coming now Michael Crabtree said
that he acknowledged that Jackson is a
baller but that he's still trying to
learn the offense understand coverages
and continue on his way to getting there
so I saw the way ahead of the curve but
then when I read the articles all these
he's ahead of the curve but yeah he's
still working on his accuracy still
doesn't know the playbook all that which
is his expected he's a rookie right then
Marty mourning leg also said about Joe
Flacco quote he's moving and grooving
better than ever which is really
interesting we did that story two weeks
ago Flacco's more mobile he's running
around he's leading out with his
receiver has never done that before Eric
Weddle said quote I expect Joe to have a
career year this year and him to lead
our team to the playoffs
the writer Jamison Hemsley also said
there's no QB controversy in Baltimore
because Flacco is throwing the ball at a
different level than Jackson and rg3 I
mean okay there's a lot here alright so
first let's just hit on the Flacco thing
I think I would expect Flacco to have a
pretty big year to I think it's gonna be
a selection Patrick Mahoney is the first
year he's really had a poker in his ass
where somebody's like oh yeah you think
this is just going
be a picnic on and you can just be Joe
and act whoever you want and youth might
throw an interception and the defense
will bail you out but I'm getting paid
so much I'm not going anywhere now Joe
before the contract was a very
underrated football player like he
really was
Joe Flacco first of all his arm it is a
special arm it's special and a dozen TV
doesn't do it justice a little bit like
Tom Brady where because there's such big
guys and they're very long they can
throw the ball very hard without minimal
effort and it doesn't give you the
theatrics maybe of what Aaron Rodgers
looks like at times oh yeah right just
doesn't look the same but I can promise
you having seen these people in person
and having caught bright balls from Tom
Brady before that the M everett can hum
it in there okay
and Flacco III do think is one of those
guys when people see him in person you
go wolf I mean it's like it's 350 yards
down the middle a drive down the middle
of the fairway once again like he's that
kind of thrower yeah I do think the
Ravens gonna be a better football team I
do think the Ravens are gonna be a
playoff football team of course I expect
them to be better this year first look
at the roster they got talent in every
position this is best to rob while
receiving they can stay here see exactly
they never had a receiving corps like
this first so they got hayden hurst in
the first round he has a very good tight
end like I'm excited about him you love
Willie sneaky Willie Snead John Brown
crab trap tree right to add to the mix
so he's first time he's got weapons and
morning wings getting to put his full
stamp on the other likes running backs
exactly so I would expect that to now
Lamar Jackson I ahead of the curve okay
well we don't know where they thought
the curve was so it's such a broad
statement their point they might had a
gigantic curve and he's a little bit
ahead of it they may have expected
nothing right exactly right so I look at
that and just go there I know a little
bit from down there that there's
basically what you said there's a lot of
impressive things these definitely
eye-opening at times with some of the
balls he throws and things like that but
learning the offense consistency on
accuracy there's still work to be done
there yet it's not perfect but I think
they're very excited about leaving a lot
of quotes about doubl quarterbacks and
both guys touching the ball one place
yeah do you think your dad's bet of five
quarterback snaps in week
is still gonna happen I don't I think
he's I don't think it'll happen I don't
think cuz my dad I think said five like
true he's in shock underneath yes I'm
gonna say it's like two and then he's on
the field like five other plays maybe
ten other plays in the game where he's
lined up at the running back or a slot
receiver something like that kick I mean
who knows oh man I know but the one
thing I've heard is from him to his and
a little bit like his film he is better
with the harder throws than he is with
the easier throws at times really he I
think you're hearing from you it shows
consistent accuracy throwing the ball
down the field but the five-yard gel
across is like 50/50 hmm right so we'll
see where it goes but I think things are
all pointing in the right direction for
this with the right coaching staff yeah
without a doubt hard balls gonna try and
do some stuff Oh what let's get to yeah
that's good to the next day hmm
interesting
first one training camps have already
started for the Ravens and bears last
week because they have the Hall of Fame
game in Canton some rookie camps are
starting some tomorrow other camps
actual camps are starting mainly a lot
of the main training camps are starting
Wednesday but John Harbaugh had a little
thing about training camps he said
acclamation is very important if we can
get a week instead of two days not to
push it back so we have a shorter time
to get our football balls football guys
ready to put in front of training camp
where we can get our guys to ramp up for
the collisions and hard movements maybe
we could avoid some of those first two
to three day injuries that we get during
training camp
that's our goal this year so the Ravens
are implementing that now they're
implementing about a week of kind of
ramping it up slowly we say this all the
time Wednesday Thursday I'm gonna hate
the song I predicted there's gonna be
like five major ACL you gotta go full
hundred percent I got a see if my pro
ball running back it's still a Pro
Bowler five months after the fact yeah
so they go full-speed they make a hard
cut your body's not used to exploding at
that speed and then down right like
Wednesday Thursday Friday there's gonna
be about six or seven ACL injuries
hamstring pulls all the soft tissue
stuff ISM and then you're gonna see an
article
that says ACL epidemic it strikes out of
nowhere and I've told you all every year
there's an average of 26 to 27 ACL
injuries before week 1 and usually most
of them happened this week so let's see
which team slowly ease into it Ravens
got hit with a lot of injuries last year
definitely hit out like all the time
oh gosh I mean they lost Brent urban
Marshall yonder yes I mean they were out
I mean then a ton Ronnie Stanley was out
for periods of time they lost their left
starting guard Alex Lewis for the whole
year so there was a ton of players so
that's why they're gonna ease into it
you think this is really smart I think
it is really smart I mean I think so
much of John Harbaugh I think he's a guy
of course he lives it and he's always
thinking about this and he is it he does
a really good job I think of putting
himself in the players shoes and asking
what's realistic of a player I think
more teams should follow this mold where
maybe you cut the offseason program off
a week or two earlier right you get out
June 5th and buy yourself more time then
because I if I was a head coach would
rather instead of my guys coming in on
July 28th I might be like you know what
I want everybody there July 21st
we won't grind you into the ground too
early but we're gonna get in shape have
some practices a little film I'll let
you go home in a decent hour
and then after like the fifth or sixth
day training camp we'll really start to
the normal you told guys you get out
earlier in July but you come back
earlier towards the end of July and you
were that open with them would they like
that I don't know I don't know she was
are tough with Jay it is tough with
change the first thing I thought about
is Mike Shanahan back in the day with
the Denver Broncos he used to do this
where he would have like basically June
would be off for the players but he
would have them back not long after the
July 4th and even have some OTAs and do
that because he didn't want them to go
that long period of time of nothing and
I understand that and I think that is a
little bit of a problem you know high
school college football they don't go
that long without it you know the
college kids most of them are down there
on campus they're working out they're
doing their own seven-on-seven stuff
they're staying ready college kids I
mean heist
kids I'm here in the wherever you are
we're going to seven-on-seven camp we're
playing in this league for
seven-on-seven
we're doing conditioning all that so it
never stops leading into the NFL season
NFL football players a lot of the times
are in this great shape then they go
home and they do nothing for three weeks
and then they try to revamp up like 10
days before Simon let me get back into
like real good shape again and you're
not quite where you need to be like you
said when the bullets are flying you
also know I got to make a cut at 100%
here and get through the line of
scrimmage one guy that will not be a
training camp at least to start is Josh
Gordon he had a Twitter post in which he
said a part of my overall health and
treatment plan I'm not coming in John
Dorsey came out and said we will
continue to support Josh as he receives
the care needed to maintain his progress
we were going to respect his privacy
while he is away from the team Josh will
be placed on the non football is illness
reserve list until he's ready to return
Adam Schefter then came out and tweeted
that Josh Gordon did not have any
slip-ups or failed tests poor's /
sources and that he is working his ass
off Florio then came on the top of that
on pro football talked and said if I
were a betting man I'd wager this is
inaccurate the NFL would not have a
reason to say they'll address Gordon
status at the appropriate time if he had
no slip-ups or failed tests I put a few
things together who was the one person
that got Baker Mayfield right Adam
Schefter right so that this is clearly
chef ders coming from John Dorsey this
was always our concern with Josh Gordon
and your first thought was I don't
believe this well I don't know if he
failed to draw I'm not I don't know
about that yeah I mean this I believe
there's some relapse yeah there must
have been some relapse I mean we didn't
just like no I'm not gonna show up for
training camp because I just you know I
don't mean I don't even know what to say
for the guy that the evidence we have
out there and his past history it shows
me relapse for the NFL to say they were
what looking into the matter and they
weren't gonna do anything as of yet
right well in a players case like a Josh
Gordon
when you've been suspended for a year
like the policy says like any player
reinstated a year or more after
banishment a clear link between
something anything happening and in
another banishment so that to me means
there could have been something so he
might have been drunk one night or
whatever he might have not got drug test
- the next morning didn't see the
alcohol in his system but maybe he got
worried it was like damn I've had two
nights in a row where I got drunk I
don't know those are just the things
that are going through Matt he didn't
not just show up for his own bike oh I'm
not showing up because I want to hang
out in Anguilla for a few more days so
there's got to be something there and
this is I just would like to say this is
the reason why I did not put them as one
of the top five trios okay so at Jarvis
Landry who sent Instagram posts of
crying laughing crying emoji
I'm gonna send back thinking emoji I
wonder why I didn't put you guys in the
top three trio this was your fear it's
it's all speculation I don't assign I
thought that he had I hope he's turned
the corner I hope so tooth rooting for
no doubt as a person as a player always
that's why I couldn't put them in there
not only because him Corey Coleman
hasn't been healthy in his career yet so
like okay there's potential assume
whatever you make an ass out of you and
me right if you assume things are gonna
be good that's all right speaking of
interesting and not showing up Kevin
Dodd not showing up either in two
Tennessee Titans camp and you're kind of
seeing a wave of these guys well I I
just I don't really get the Kevin Dodd
one I don't understand that Tennessee
Titans pass rusher out of Clemson yeah
thirty third pick in the draft a few
years back same as Shaq Lawson and Kevin
Dodd though the one thing I would be
looking at it's just man he's he's in a
defense that's really gonna suit him now
with just Raven Harold Landry right they
got Harold Landry I mean Iraq pose
getting up there in age right I just
would look at that and go man I would
think there's gonna be some role Mike
variables your head coach he wasn't
gonna try to make you and to my great
and you know our defensive coordinator
from Baltimore has their peen piece yeah
but it's interesting that Shaq Lawson
and Kevin Dodd have not turned out
anything
dominated that college football
championship for
yeah dominate I'll say this if you
remember back and did not trust check
loss I never trust the check I did trust
God I did I thought Kevin Dodd had
potential so I could be wrong there and
it looks like I am wrong at this point
yes shock Lawson was one of those guys
where I'd never said I'd you know and
again I don't know yeah he was the 19th
pick of the draft somewhere he went to
Buffalo cuz you know records on this
tension right so I think he got over
drafted because of that but yeah I find
that peculiar whether the the Kevin Dodd
situation especially for a guy who's not
lived up to his billing to this point in
his career last hmm interesting
Darrelle Revis our good friend retired
and I saw that Josh found the old clip
of us interviewing him and we were
asking what his spirit animal was and I
forgot I said that he was a spider you
know what I mean because he's got his
web and you come into Annie attacks
well the NFL Instagram posted a picture
of him with T Oh Calvin Johnson Randy
Moss and their stats against him each
played three games against him tío had
eight he caught eight balls for 46 yards
no touchdown one interception
Calvin Johnson caught four balls for 57
yards no touchdown no interception
that's incredible incredible Randy Moss
had nine catches 88 yards two touchdowns
one interception and one was that
one-handed catch in the back of it when
he just burned him like that was the
first time that I saw Revis get burned
and that was sort of when people went
this Patriots $0.20 2017 is pretty
incredible
so NFL wrote as their caption even the
best receivers were left stranded on
Revis Island Randy Moss commented
underneath it and he's really paying
attention in the social media lately
it's no island when you got safety help
stop fooling yourself he's a great
cornerback but come on
and then commented again not taken from
Revis because he's a great cornerback
and very talented Deion Sanders played
on an island with no safety help all I'm
saying
I think Randy's wrong I'm sorry really
sorry Randy
yeah I knew you were gonna disagree this
is an island Bill Belichick didn't pay
wanna pay
him forty million a year because he said
oh yeah safety help I mean that's that's
erroneous
that's where ego gets into some of these
Hall of Fame pyres so you disagree with
Randy Moss totally he lived on an island
I watched a ton of film on Darrelle
Revis Darrelle Revis when I was working
in New England I mean it was obsessive I
had to make special tapes of Darrelle
Revis and this is when he wasn't on the
team you know he was in New York and I
was working for the Patriots and they
wanted him he was on an island without a
doubt now so the case no he lived in
Island more than anybody I know
other than Deion Sanders and I had this
conversation with my dad a few days ago
because I you know I my stance I think
Darrelle Revis
is the second best corner of our
lifetime to me he had a seven-year
period there where I mean he had an
island named after him and he shut down
people like that and there wasn't great
safety help he's totally wrong with that
I don't know I don't agree with that at
all and Rex Rex Ryan's defenses are not
to safety defenses in the most part
especially when he was in the Jets and
that time but the other thing I would
say and when I said this to my dad just
add some context he goes oh yeah he's
pretty awesome I know my dad said he
would take Doral Darryl Greene and Mike
Haynes from the Raiders over Darrelle
Revis so he was number four from my dad
he's number two for me and I know I
don't have the experience against my
canes or Darryl Greene like my dad does
but the area I push back against my dad
is man Darryl Greene and Mike Haynes
could do a whole lot more with their
hands and the things that Darrelle Revis
would have been illegal they would have
said no that's a penalty you can't do
that you can't push the guy 20 yards
down the field and knock him down that's
against the rules and Darrelle Revis
wasn't allowed to do some of those
things so yeah I you disagree with rayon
totally and I usually don't this is
Randy's the man and Randy really pays
attention but I don't know why he said
must be ego and that one in the past
year talking about was not in the 2007
season well it was this year he gets
traded to the Minnesota Vikings and then
goes somewhere else after that yeah it
was past Randy's prime was it yeah it
was just there was no safety in the
middle of the field on that play by it
by just let you know it was a post down
the middle and he caught it in the back
of the end zone yeah I'm gonna say that
was like 2009
Wow yeah all right I knew you're gonna
disagree with Randy there cuz I know
that Rivas is your guy you said it right
to us he's my guide to man I like Randy
I just you know I just don't agree with
that one all right let's talk a little
money we got to fill people in Odell is
here or delegate you should get some
money speaking of the Giants say qualm
Barkley fully guaranteed contract yeah
four years 31.2 fully guaranteed twenty
point eight million dollar signing bonus
I've never seen a fully guaranteed
rookie contract before yes you have yeah
which people there's been a lot of them
have there yeah they're as even in the
recent after they switched from the Sam
Bradford oh yeah that's when you've seen
them the fully guaranteed yes because
it's like oh okay it's a 25 million
dollar guarantees for five years who the
hell cares
I mean that's gonna cost them what
twenty million it was a four-year deal
for thirty-one so that's eight million
dollar average right all right so wait
hold on and then you can I mean he's
gonna count almost nothing against the
cap to give them the signing bonus that
gets cut in half too because that's how
the formula works oh yeah at the end of
the day I mean I'm not surprised by this
this is usually what high draft picks
get it's a slotted type of money that
just goes up a few million dollars per
year yeah and I was not shocked to see
this it's just crazy in terms of cap
it's a call Barclay is the eighth
highest running back he's a highest yeah
what is it what is ahead of Devonta
Freeman what what's his uh
you got it right there a 5.6 million
yeah number one is levy on number two is
Jerick McKinnon number three is LeSean
McCoy then Zeke then Lamar Miller Lamar
Miller Oh Lamar Miller what's he Texans
he's at a six point seven five okay so
here you're getting I mean that's
amazing it just tells you how low it is
well we're getting say Kwan Barkley good
probably gonna be the most explosive
player in football this year for a five
million a year whoa big offseason it's
incredible it's incredible it's why
they're getting screwed in by the Hilton
he might be beat to [ __ ] by the time he
wants a new contract there you go oh
you're beat up your quads aren't as big
anymore because we've had nine million
people chop them down since we give you
the ball the time now we can't pay you
anymore
while the guy that's trying to change
this for all the running backs Le'Veon
Bell his cap hit with this franchise tag
is 14.5 million so he's far and away the
most at running back but he's trying to
get a long-term deal and it sounds like
a lot of guarantees he turned down a
contract Ian Rapoport who I'm just gonna
say this I know it's the NFL reporters
job to just give the information that
they're given yeah but when it's [ __ ]
propaganda I think it's kind of
malicious
so when Rapoport comes out and says
Le'Veon Bell turned down a five-year
seventy million dollar contract and then
everyone starts blowing up about how
Le'Veon bells greedy and he never put
out the guarantees he never put out any
of the details that is the NFL teams
playbook on how to fight the public
against the player you put out a number
and and the comments are will I make
minimum wage well you're not an NFL
player so shut the [ __ ] up
but that was a little bit too much but
the truth is is I think it's almost
messed up for a reporter to put out any
contract information without the
guarantees because those contracts do
not matter those numbers don't matter I
don't know why it's still being reported
it is a tactic for NFL teams to ally
innate their players so that every NFL
team saying and after every NFL team
made two hundred and fifty five million
dollars in revenue that's before ticket
sales that's before convenient sales as
before jersey sales and yet here we are
going levy on you're gonna turn down
fourteen million dollars yes because I'm
already getting 14 and a half for my
franchise tag right I don't understand
why the public always takes side with
the billionaires and I guess Ian needed
to break the story cuz he got the
information I just think it's propaganda
and eventually reporters need to realize
that they are being tools used to put
forth propaganda I know it's really
annoying how the public doesn't want to
give players respect it the football's a
little guy thought about this a lot over
the last leg falls a little different
because people are
they're true to this the emblem like
it's the Eagles it's the Giants they
really care about that they really care
about the team the Jersey where other
sports it's about the player and this
fans vouch for the player more than they
do from abroad fan trout fan I'm an
Aaron judge fan whatever it is so yes so
that's where football players hurt I
don't get it either did eleda blatant
disrespect I'm not gonna get on Ian
Rapoport first of all that's just the
information he was given right I don't I
know Ian well enough to know that he'd
be on the players side more times than
not for sure okay he's a good dude and I
would say this is well where I just am
surprised with the Pittsburgh that they
would even try these propaganda moves
its propagated right totally propaganda
I mean you're totally right on that
aspect it's not even like debatable I
mean five years 70 million oh okay great
yeah I mean so what and they offered him
what did it say it would see million
over there great over the first to
guarantee and then I think it was a ten
million dollar signing bonus
why the [ __ ] would he do gree to that
what what why and to me it shows that
the Steelers really only believed in him
for two more years and pretty much I
think it's very it's very rescue there's
no way he can sign that deal that's what
I mean so if you're getting 33 over the
first two years guaranteed let's see
there's 43 total then that means there's
27 million dollars of imaginary money
that Rappaport put out there that he's
not gonna see goes in with that 33
so it's don't don't make it forty three
thirty three oh that's just the 33 ten
million signing bonus is part of the 33
seven there's 37 million dollars that
was released to the public that does not
exist and he will not see offered him
five years 33 million two million more
than say Quan Barkley who hasn't done
[ __ ] yet so I'm saying and he had an
extra year and his thing so do you think
the say Quan deal being all guaranteed
and being that amount of money that
levian would use it or is he passed that
point I think he's passed that he's
passed it now I don't think let me on
Belkin asked for 17 million a year
that's not realistic but I do think it's
realistic for him to ask and command
somewhere between 12 and 14 I don't
think that's crazy
12 14 1 million a year I don't think
that's right yeah dude he wants 15 to 7
I know I won so I don't think he's gonna
get that
that's realistic I don't think you can
sit there and go I'm gonna make 10
million more per year than any other
running back in the sport he's awesome
but he ain't twice as good as LeSean
McCoy
he ain't like three times better than
the zql yeah I mean so that's the only
thing I'm gonna push back on you know I
like levia and I'm not trying to hate on
them and I want them to get paid but I
do think set between 15 and 17 is not
realistic
I do think somewhere between 12 and 14
and a half is I think my thing though
with levy on bail that's kind of tough
is that I look at levy on he's 26 years
old he's the only running back in NFL
history with three seasons of 1,200
yards rushing 600 yards receiving nine
touchdowns by the time he turned 25 he
had and he had 94 catches last season he
had a hundred and something targets he
had more targets than your team's
number-one receiver so he look I look at
say Quan say Quan said right after the
draft there was an article that came out
and the headline was Giants sake when
Berkeley I'm not just a running back I
think that the they're gonna kill the
running back position but Le'Veon is
more than just a run he gets lined up at
wide receiver at a time I think there's
a lot of running backs that could do
that though - that's where I would push
back just for argument's sake right
again I have a great respect for Le'Veon
he's the man but I do think like there's
a good 10 running backs in football that
I think if you put them in Pittsburgh's
offense their numbers would be very
similar there were some reports that he
might sit out a bunch of the season I
come back we've always said the the best
situation would be sit out until week 10
right then play those final six game be
credited season get your credited season
I think for levy on bail it makes the
most sense I don't I wouldn't be any or
just show up right before the season
starts and again I'm not gonna be any
mad but put minimal effort Oh me a
hamstring Soraa can't really run til
Sunday sorry guys so Aaron Donnell
doesn't have a contract
Le'Veon doesn't have a contract O'Dell
doesn't have a contract we owe Mac all
our favorites all my man crushes Jon
Gruden had a quote that was really bad I
thought what he was like man it's is
really hard we got to figure this out I
got to figure this out yeah and I went
one you're not the GM
so like clearly your acting is GM like
you just said that Reggie McKenzie like
you need to figure this out you just
said but to the coach is always supposed
to say I want to pay this guy yeah let's
get him pay let's get him on the field
Gruden's back here acting like the GM
and he's not the GM well we don't know
what he's that's what I'm saying like
you got to watch what you say grind no
you know what this is one thing he
doesn't care and now I believe I said
this a few weeks back where I said it
will only be a matter of time before his
head wants to pop off with this Kaleo
Mac situation he knows that this guy's a
stud this is the best player on his
plate he may have no chance not none so
he's gonna go crazy he's gonna drive
everybody in the front office and
ownership crazy until it gets done he's
not gonna fret about he's you know he's
cool where he he's not gonna be like
this isn't my extra five million dollars
but I want him on that [ __ ] team so
I'll pay it to him never yeah he wants
the player he's on the side of the
player when it comes to stuff like that
it's July yeah we've been having this
conversation about these four players
too since it's so annoying but here's my
question VIN how many of them actually
get a deal done what's your what's your
July updated prediction
Donald Odell levian and Mac I think I
think Donald and Mac definitely get a
hundred percent okay I think they're
gonna get it Le'Veon is not gonna get
anything I don't think he gets anything
and I think that mmm Odell was like a
coin toss right now I mean if he made me
pick I'm gonna say he gets it towards
the end of training camp but he's
definitely wish watch I'm pretty common
that levian doesn't get anything done
and I'm confident that Khalil and Mac
Khalil Mac and Aaron Donald do get it
done yes but then the Odell situation
and I look at and go it's a coin flip I
think what's really crazy to me with the
air in Donald's situation is the amount
of money that went to brain and cooks
yeah and it's like that was your
priority that's who you wanted to lock
down my predictions I think Khalil Mack
is the first one to get a deal I think
that Odell gets a deal the week of the
first game I think it's like the week
before he gets a new deal I think that
levian is going to hold out and I do
think he misses games and I also think
that Aaron Donald is gonna miss some
games you do Ivan
Aaron Donald for me it sounds like
they're really at a standstill and if
there's one guy that has a lot of
leverage
it's the 20-something year old guy
coming off a defensive player of the
year after shattering records four sacks
at his position in this first few years
he's he has Khalil Mack I could make a
lot of arguments that there are some
things in his game that are better than
Aaron Donald's game he's younger than
levy on Bell's current situation he
doesn't have the off the field stuff
like Odell Beckham which I don't think
they're an issue but for some people
they do but Aaron Donald is the perfect
person that has also mentioned holdouts
before and he's in LA and you know
girlies in here talking early he's been
talking about money the whole offseason
the whole Rams team is talking about
money now he's got an endowment consume
X to him he's got to keep to leave next
to him he's got Marcus Peters back there
he's got a lot of people they're gonna
go get paid ya get paid I think Donald's
gonna miss some games too I think I'll
be shocked
I mean he's min I mean Aaron darling
he's on pace to be a first-ballot
hall-of-famer yes I'm safe and you're
you're right about the Brandon cook
situation first thing I thought of now
it really shouldn't affect him like I
have the contract situation in front of
my eyes
it's 8.4 million dollars a year okay all
right you know he got a five-year deal
he got 20 million guaranteed it was
right at the signing okay so that only
counts five years in 220 million only
counts four million against the cap
right so yeah I mean eight million 8.4
million a year that's nothing
yes again that's NFL propaganda in
itself there you go it's a five-year I
would it's really what it is is a
five-year it's really a three-year right
I'm gonna say it's a 3 year 36 million
dollar deal that's well that's what
Brandon cuts got yeah basically because
everything else is back loaded it was
funny when I was arguing about for levy
on on on Twitter a lot of I brought up
Sammy Watkins contract and a lot of lot
of Chiefs fans got upset and said why is
it that every contract dispute that
comes up everyone's bringing up Sammy
Watkins like he sucks and I said it's
not that he sucks
it's that Sammy Watkins has missed a lot
of time and has not had the
moments right and yet he still got paid
yeah
Le'Veon was been suspended multiple
times missed a number of games got
injured because of an tez Burfict it's
an easy comp because they both missed
time and same he still got 16 yeah and
where I would also argue - with Sammy
and no point has he ever been in the
conversation from one of the five best
receivers in football not even the 10
best know where levy on bail is in the
top three conversation the last three
four years one guy always in our top
three Julio Jones Atlanta Falcons come
out and says they are not giving Julio
Jones a new deal will that spillover to
the season because Julio seemed pissed
when all this stuff was going down I
don't think that fades away I don't
think so either I I think Julio's like I
don't know maybe too good of a guy to be
just like totally disgruntled I wish she
was seen more of Huli on camera this
offseason than any officer yeah I know
different project definitely has the
right to be disappointed he really does
I I don't know I don't know how this is
gonna play out I really don't I think
with Julio I mean just everything he
showed me throughout his career is that
he's a team guy and he doesn't want
attention for the wrong reasons and I
think he'll end up playing that's gonna
be my guess you think he's in a I think
this I think that if I'm an agent for a
player I'm only doing three year deals
I'm trying to do the NBA model for NFL
players right dear NFL team I'm not
interested in your five years six years
seven year deal it's been a little thing
of propaganda that you've been using no
one sees the last few years I only want
three year deals in the honor of Kirk
Cousins getting three years 84 all
guaranteed I'd like a lot of guaranteed
money - do you not trust me why I'm
guaranteed I I'm here I'm guaranteed the
other reason CBA is up in three years
right so if I get a three year deal I'm
getting all my money it's all I'm
getting all of it if I get a four year
deal I might not see that fourth year I
might not see that fifth year I don't
know what's gonna happen what's gonna
get torn up how's it gonna go
I want my contract aligned with the CBA
if the percentages change I want to be
able to negotiate with those new
percentages of revenue sharing if
there's a stop
work my contract is over I can go and do
whatever I want right now I'm only doing
a 3-year deal for a number of reasons
one being let's get on these NBA
contracts and stop it a long term and
also the CBA yeah
what do you think of that I do I mean I
I do think that the guaranteed contract
may be lesser total number chance to get
back at the negotiating table quicker is
gonna become the fad in the NFL has to
like what's the point what's what not to
right I mean it's we're seeing we're
learning especially through these stars
that of course the back ends of these
contracts are so loaded and the team's
never live up never and like never it's
been like five people in the history of
the sport that have like seemed the
total amount of their it's like Tony
Romo Tommy people like that far but
still think is like the only guy ever to
see like a hundred million dollars of
the hundred million dollar contract so
now I think there's gonna be other guys
that coming along that are gonna also do
that but yeah it's just I do think
that's gonna be the wave of the future
because guys are gonna go let me just
get as much now and a better myself so I
can get back to the table and get more
later all right let's get into some
interesting quotes and we got two quotes
here from guys that I don't really not
that big of a fan of it they had good
quotes first ones speaking about money
Blake bortles damn good quote bortles
talking about Tom Brady's contract quote
I think definitely the way that tom has
done it is the way to try to model
having guys and putting pieces around
him was definitely something when you
take up a ton of money you kind of limit
your team and who they can help you out
with and put around you I'm not naive
enough to say that we don't need a
running game we also need a good defense
receiver so we know those pieces you
can't play as a quarterback and do it
yourself so I'm willing to take less
money than someone else might in my
position to put good guys around us one
completely agree right
two good self propaganda for himself
it's also like oh I took less money
because I didn't want a lot nobody was
gonna offer you anything yeah they
probably were gonna only offer you that
if that you know the other thing though
is Blake bortles could be a very
troublesome for us because you have been
intertwined with Blake bortles right if
because he's not taking some
the rest of the team is great we just
saw this Eagles Minnesota Jacksonville
in the Final Four
none of them had a great quarterback
Nick Foles Case Keenum Blake bortles but
the rest of the team was good Blake
bortles and the Jaguars could be good
for a very long time yeah because he's
willing to take a little bit less money
they they could I mean it's the most
talented team in football that's not
even arguable I mean that's it's not I
mean they should have been home field
advantage in the playoffs last year if
they had a quarterback that wasn't
number 70 I'm sorry you think there's a
misconception about Tom Brady yeah I
think the Tom Brady things way overboard
listen I know Tom Brady early in his
career he literally said to the New
England Patriots
I won't take one less penny than Peyton
Manning who was the highest-paid player
in football so don't get that that first
is wrong the other thing that's wrong
too is Tom isn't raising his hand to the
New England Patriots going I'll take
less I'll take less now he got the
benefit of marrying a woman that's
making 43 million dollars a year so
that's awesome
but I know for a fact New England has
given him ultimatums like this is what
we're paying you and that's it and they
say guess it's for the betterment of the
team but it's not like they're just like
oh it's not like Tom going like Oh bill
I'll take ten million less it's okay no
the New England doesn't give a [ __ ]
about anybody they've gone
what is it 14 and six without Tom Brady
Belichick in that regime think they can
win with a lot of quarterbacks so you're
also the public goes man Tom Brady is so
generous he doesn't need it I was there
in 2012 everything I had been led to
believe is they'd strong-armed Tom Brady
like here's the deal and if you want to
be the quarterback of the team there it
is
and if you don't then go ahead now I
don't know if it would've ever got to
that point I think mr. Kraft would have
massage but Brady was also smart enough
and he is good enough at checking his
ego to go okay he can see the big
picture and go it's pretty good here I
can take a little less I got a ton of
money and my wife makes a shitload of
money so we're good but for everybody
this that's that's not true all the time
that Brady's just like raising his hand
in the bell oh yeah me oh I'll take I'll
take ten million less than all the other
quarterbacks in football he's not
volunteering that that's just wrong it
does seem to be the public perception
it's not right ittsan sorry with that
being said man he's being strong-armed
like they're telling them you got to
take the leafless that's the way they
are with everybody it doesn't matter I
mean oh it's so you're Chandler Jones
you help this one a sewer boy let the
other phone sex get the hell out of here
you're gonna ask for too much money
Jamie Collins are you're not stuck get
the hell out of here
lawyer Milloy we've been and we've been
indebted to you forever and you've done
everything get the hell out of here it
doesn't matter he runs it like a
business bill belichick can be the coach
of the team this is where he's great
where he is the coach of the team and he
can relate to the players but then he
can go upstairs in the front office and
have no soul and make a business
decision that's the brilliance of Bill
Belichick and a lot other coaches can't
separate them all right I'm gonna skip
some of these and I want to get right to
make me sound like a Brady hater again
that's not a Brady here I know no but I
think it's this notion that Tom Brady is
this sixth round pick that's an
all-american guy that just wants to win
championships and he's super nice and
all that it's like no also realize this
Brady will grab an offensive lineman by
the face and MFM until he actually
changes his ways he's not giving up a
lot of money the Patriots and the
business they are patriots Incorporated
are telling them this is how much and he
can spin it and say it's all good for
exactly right we're not saying you're
not saying that Patriot that that Tom
Brady is a faker but I think that when
it comes to Tom Brady we're willing to
put everything into the hero box yeah
everything right everything he does is
supposed to be so incredible that's
right that's right and I just don't
think he is yeah no he's incredible but
yes it's not everything has to be
incredible uh a lot it's been the other
theme of the offseasons people feeling
comfortable taking shots at the Patriots
they lost the Super Bowl and everybody
said you know what
mm [ __ ] those guys I'm gonna take a shot
at them and I love it I think it's great
first one Jason Kelsey at a radio show
talk about the Patriots quote the last
defense we had seen was Minnesota's and
we were like these dudes have some
players then we see the Patriots and
were like these dudes have some coaches
but we've always said so what everybody
says
remember the Super Bowl every guy Super
Bowl radio row was like
really aren't that good Melvin Gordon's
like we're more talented than the
Patriot right there's not a lot of years
that's that is the greatness of
Belichick because there's been a lot of
years where they go to the AFC
championship game and I'm gonna go damn
I mean realistically this year they're
like the eighth best team in the AFC
talent-wise but here they are in the AFC
championship because of their ability to
execute because of Brady all of that
stuff yes and we knew that I mean come
on knowing those defense suck this year
sucks suck that's what people forget
after that ninth in football 251 yards
passing per game remember after that
Bucs game they went on a tear where they
were the number one school defense right
and that's what they do they're
phenomenal at stopping you in the red
zone they certainly are but nobody is
scared of New England's talent is you
know like 2014 when they had like
Hightower and Jamie Collins yeah and
Ning kovitch was still playing that
Seahawks team that they play but Revis
at one corner I mean they were good that
with defense was like I was a GU that's
there's some men on that before safety
right right but no this last year yeah
it's it was really only three guys right
we talked about we saw who are the three
Malcom Malcom Butler Gilmore and
McCourty we were like those are really
the defense hinged on their ability to
do things that other people they're
pretty weird they have holes that
they're secondary now but they're gonna
get Hightower back and it's there's
still a [ __ ] with Sheldon I wouldn't
bet against those guys ever no it's also
been the off season of former Patriots
leaving and talking [ __ ] so Cassius
Marsh talked a lot of crap a lot of
people said whatever Danny haven't done
shouldn't even be get classified as a
former Patriot therefore like a drink of
water
Danny Amendola on the difference between
Adam GaSe the coach of Miami and Bill
Belichick coach case is one of the guys
he's our leader he's our head coach but
he's also our boy it's cool it's
refreshing you had that kind of
relationship with a coach something I
haven't had in a long time back in New
England it's almost like you had a
principal and a principal's office and
[ __ ] like that in a good way and a bad
way too so it sounds like Amendola was
really tired it it seems like it off
easy to get it easy ball goes back to
Malcolm Butler Brady got tired grunt got
tired haven't totally got tired it's a
grind and Belichick doesn't make it a
fairy tale every day he's just he's not
there to tell you how
awesome you are now you do want to feel
appreciated and I think that's where you
get a point where you just get a fed-up
be like damn I've given everything to
these guys for five years straight like
everything and he still owes only gave
me like one compliment in five years I
think that's what starts to wear on the
players more than anything and an Adam
GaSe is one of the cool design cases a
great dude and he's got a great way
about him as far as he doesn't go too
far into being like one of the dudes
yeah he can be very blunt and
in-your-face and he's tough I'll bet you
five dollars that he cuts to offensive
line in the middle of the season yeah
he's like what he does every year I mean
come on what he did this year those are
big moves got Jarvis Landry and Dominic
ensue out of there I mean you know gays
has done good things in Miami and and
the other thing too you know again why
we're gonna sit here and pile on Bill
like okay that's oh it's not Bill's the
principle yeah well he's the [ __ ]
principle that's got five Super Bowl
rings
I know number one school the school
district for you twenty years runner you
show me like a cool who's a cool awesome
coach in history that's like well Chuck
Knowles not yeah Tom Landry was Joe
Walsh was it right Nestle Bharti was
know quite you know band leader the only
guy I can really think of in all sports
where I go they had a Phil Jackson
exactly right Phil Jax was the only guy
could go he seemed like not a dictator
and he still won six NBA championships
oh man he had the greatest player ever
in the history of the game on his team
I'm sorry about six of the but you're
right but here here's a good one yeah
James Harrison just played for Belichick
right also played for Mike Tomlin right
ones a cool guy ones Bill Belichick
right James Harrison said Mike Tomlin is
a is good as a head coach he's a
player's coach I think he needs to be a
little bit more discipline okay
very interest yeah the thing goes on the
big thing with Belichick is he's very
regimented he's disciplined everyone is
going to be on the same page there's not
going to be anything as far as someone
doing their own thing I think over there
their whole coaching staff is like that
asked what Tomlin could do to upgrade
his player discipline discipline
Harrison said just being more consistent
across the board with everything from
your stars to your special teams players
you think he's tell Tonio
or Big Ben he's talking about all of
them I mean because they've all had
their own little rulebook that they've
gotten away with stuff that but Tomlin's
the cool super bowl tamil I would never
put him in the same regard as Phil Bella
well I mean it's not it who is in the
realm of felt that's the problem with
this statement like oh I mean Hakeem
Olajuwon was awesome but he's now
Michael Jordan no [ __ ] thank you I mean
thank you for pointing that out so I
mean he listen he's still got a problem
with the Steelers we know that so
someone that's personal but like that's
just not like nobody is comparable to
Bill Belichick he's the greatest coach
in the history of the sport
yeah Tomlin's are really really good
football coach he's not Bill Belichick
and I've yet to be around or know
anybody that is so I don't think that's
fair I mean I just it's not to me it's
it's it's very easy from the outside
they say you should want to play for a
Bill Belichick I think for those guys
the best way to do it is what Amendola
has done right play for Bill win your
Super Bowls and then go somewhere else
and be like man that was really I bet
you James Harrison wouldn't been able to
do all those cool like Instagram videos
in the New England locker and the New
England waitress burger he didn't seem
to have a problem mike tomlin then yeah
it was okay then the show his biceps in
his chest and he didn't he wore a
sweatshirt not too until I know but he
didn't do those in New England you never
noticed that but just you know know yeah
well I don't think James Harrison was
taking a shot at anybody there I think
James Harrison was just stating a fact
I know but you don't have I mean like I
I think he getting done in a more gentle
way you thought that him say so you
think that was actually a slight thing
so yeah the Steelers altogether no doubt
and least in my eyes yes I've always
said that I think mike tomlin is a good
coach but I think he has a discipline
bro yeah there's certainly he's not
perfect we know that discipline Antonio
Brown has gotten away with whatever he
wants to get away with Big Ben gets away
with whatever he wants to get away with
yeah yeah I mean when you have fighting
between Euro senior coach Tomlin let's
guys do things how they're gonna do it
and and you know what that's one way to
run your ship yeah
it's putting the owner the onus on your
team to be men yeah and I think what you
learn is even though these guys are 30
years old or 28 years old and they're
profess
they're still children there's still
players on a team and and Harrison goes
to New England and goes man this is this
is my kind of locker right I think the
guys that go to New England late like
the Chris Long's yeah you might get a
little tired but they go man if I had
this my whole career I could have won so
much because it's just it's not about
the discipline on them it's the
discipline on the other people too
yes you know no it's it's it's a special
place that way and like we've always
said it's they haven't lucked into 17
years of greatness no it's not been like
oh we got lucky again for the 17th year
in a row speaking of greatness Malik
Jackson thinks that the Jaguars
I'm quote I'm calling it 16 and oh I
don't think anybody can beat us as long
as we stay healthy and do what we're
supposed to do Fowler is Dante Fowler
suspended for the first few weeks but
Malik Jackson came on our podcast last
year said they're going to the Super
Bowl this year he says they're going 16
to know and why didn't we get him on
again I know that's that's your you're
the the booking agent I should have a
Jack's Malik is the man he's a defensive
lineman 16 I know it's great to have as
a but that's not going to happen
especially the way they play now again
they're the most talented team in
football they really are but hey there
their schedule is not easy and the way
they play and the way they keep games so
close like I said I will not be shocked
if Jacksonville gets off to put two and
two sharp you're a believer that
Jacksonville is gonna fall off and I
think the best point you made is sure
their defense is amazing sure they keep
it close but the NFL is a game where the
ball bounce is a funny way right and if
that ball bounce is a little weird and
they don't get that strip sack in the
fourth quarter like they got all the
time last year or bortles is still only
putting up ten points again right you're
gonna go to New York week one you're
gonna play a very energized New York
Giants football team that's really
really gonna want to put their best foot
forward in front of their home fans New
Era
that place is gonna be rockin sure it's
gonna have all year to pick apart that's
gonna have so many tricks up his trick
up his sleeve exactly right and then oh
if you lose that game oh [ __ ]
we got Belichick and Brady coming to
town next week Wow okay so we'll see
that's what I'm saying just saying
again I still think to the most talented
team in football I'm not putting that
away but the way they play football can
lead them to some losses where you go I
love it I'm violent but I'm gonna pick
some crazy teams for my division winners
this year like I'm just hot I know
you're picking Tennessee I'm definitely
no I just think it makes so much sense
does it makes a lot of sense yeah
doesn't make sense also a damn good
point here for a [ __ ] been McAdoo I
don't talk about his ass okay I just
don't want to talk about he's a loser oh
I thought you were like literally gonna
talk about his ass like just you thought
you knew it oh no he was just saying
that he thought you did the right thing
with Eli Manning and and he really tried
to you know move on to see the future
with Davis Webb our whoa big offseason
guy and all that and I'm just like
whatever apparently it's gonna be in
Peter Kings article that comes out in
the the new website I saw some of it I
mean Ben McAdoo he and he also said that
Philadelphia is not used to handling
success I saw that I mean he's trying to
stay relevant I get that he's trying to
keep his name out there all that but I
would say that you know watch out but
things like that talking about you know
your left tackle and quarterback play
like other players are gonna look at
that around the league and go damn like
oh he's a coach on our team now you mean
the guy that got fired from the other
place and like bashed the players so
that's where you got to be careful as a
disgruntled ex coach and he also said
that he tried too hard to get Odell
opportunities earlier in the year yeah
and I don't know I didn't see any of
that well I mean most of the plays are
called for Odell but I mean it doesn't
matter if they're fourth grade plays
that's what I'm saying it was on slant
flat to throw the ball to Odell
okay so you're gonna run across the
shallow cross whoa before we get to some
fan stuff too serious news of notes
first one Tony Sparano
passes away 56 years old offensive line
coach for Minnesota former head coach I
think for the Raiders and the Dolphins
Zimmer head coach of the Vikings says
about Sparano I love Tony Sparano he was
a great teacher a grinder of a worker
and had toughness and fighting spirit
that showed in our linemen he was a
great husband father and grandfather and
a great friend to me this is just
sinking in but he will be sorely be
missed his son is that tight ends coach
for the Jacksonville Jaguars
Tony was
one of those guys that when every time I
looked at Minnesota I know their
offensive line wasn't great last year
but I felt like they kind of over
achieved with what they had and I kind
of thought with Pat F line and some of
the new faces there that this was gonna
be a really good year for Minnesota's
line I want to say condolences to the
whole Sparano family did you ever have
run-ins with Tony no run-ins he said
bill he's a Parcells coaching tree guy
right that's why he's up there in
Minnesota with Zimmer because Zimmer is
also a Parcells guy so that it stands
you know there it makes sense I've never
heard anything but good things about
Tony Sparano he's definitely been one of
the best old line coaches in football I
was 15 I've always said with Minnesota
to have a former head coach as an
offensive line coach right like those
guys Mike Munchak like they always they
have up they have a bigger perspective
they make a mark on your team that's
yeah you don't realize until they're
gone and because they can bring
toughness to the whole football team
because of the way the old line
practices makes the defensive line
tougher and you know makes the offensive
line tougher because we have an attitude
and it's third and one we're gonna run
downhill screw that you know so all
those things but hey invented the
Wildcat for the most part let's not
forget about that that's the mark he'll
leave on the game with him I didn't all
this RPO stuff there's a lot there right
let's also take into the account that
he's the only guy that won the AFC East
other than the New England Patriots over
the last 17 years they won the ALCS the
year break drive ever did I don't think
he won the AFC stay got him the playoffs
and beat the Patriots or his wild card
but no my niece Prado is the only coach
11 in five with Chad Pennington they
lost to the Ravens and Joe Flacco his
rookie year and the card game down there
remember that yeah
so that is that but he he's you know had
potential there certainly and anyone
that can come up with a wrinkle that's
gonna like really put a thorn in the
side of Belichick that was incredibly
broad out in New England with Ronnie
Brown right you're exactly right how was
it was a good game so alright beat Tony
the other one is they always tell people
in sports to stick to sports
Donald Trump made another comment about
the antibiotics spective residency he
wrote first time kneeling out for game
second time kneeling out first
and no pay it got a little interesting
Jarell Casey came out and said he'd take
the knee and his fine
the Titans came out and said jerel we
weren't gonna find you so don't be upset
with us Steve Tisch came out and said
there will be no punishments for the
Giants and that Donald Trump should
focus on what he should be focusing on
the Dolphins came out and said it's
gonna be a four-game suspension then
walked it back and said quote that
sentence was a placeholder and we
haven't made our decision yet which
means you just have this form that says
four week suspension on it like clearly
there had been discussions about it but
then after all of this the NFL and the
NFLPA came together and they are
actually having a standstill they're not
gonna say anything my my main thing is
my hope football fans can realize you
don't need to have this debate every
time realize that Donald Trump is going
through some serious allegations right
now this former lawyer Michael Cohen and
what just happened with with Putin in
Russia and he uses the NFL to distract
us he uses this anthem policy to get us
talking about something that leads
immediately to arguments and it is not
something that he's truly focused on it
is a distraction and so there's part of
me I hope he's not focused on I mean I
would think there's bigger problems in
the world in fact I know there is and
for me I just I don't really want to
talk about it's why I saved it for here
on the show because it's like I know
that he's just trying to distract us so
I'm not gonna give it the the the
attention that he wants yeah I mean I
just have a problem with the hypocrisy
I'll just leave it at that that's where
it bothers me more than anything I mean
you know that he can bother me but I
just look at it oh okay yeah you know
sit there and attack african-american
players who were standing up for
something that's very wrong in our
society and they're really trying to
stand up for something that's right that
needs to be fixed with the social and
justices and he has the gall to say
they're unamerican and yet this guy is
recently been the most unamerican
American I've ever seen I mean I've
never seen anybody disrespect our
country more
then okay the Senate Intel committee
that's investigating this it's headed by
Republicans they said the Russia
interference is real yeah the FBI whose
recent FBI director was appointed by
Donald Trump said no Russia interference
is very real yeah but he's not gonna
believe any of our things in our
democracy and he's just gonna take
Vladimir Putin's but that's fine that's
American that's very American
I mean that's he's well done I mean he's
true to the word as usual yeah and it
bothers me sorry very hypocrite yeah so
let's go to a different country then
let's go to Canada Oh Manziel has been
traded yeah hoser to Montreal Conor
O'Neill thank you sir always on the case
our embedded Canadian reporter he says
the rumors of Manziel being traded have
been proven to be true traded Sunday
evening after much speculation the
newest member of the Montreal Alouettes
they are one and four he will be playing
for Mike Sherman head coach of Texas A&M
2008 to 2011 he brought in Manziel as a
redshirt quarterback in 2011 Conor
O'Neill this is great stuff reggae stuff
the timing of the trade couldn't be more
perfect in Saturday's game against the
Calgary Stampeders Willie Drew was the
quarterback for the Alouettes left the
game of the hand injury he was also
sidelined with a concussion so Manziel
and Mike Sherman together and Montreal
great city mantra great city I've never
been there everybody says it's very
awesome I know that's actually the first
thing I thought up scary scary for
Johnny Manziel is Montreal scarier than
Toronto I think so yeah I think so too
French I've been to clubs in Montreal
the girls are phenomenal they're French
yeah great I mean Drake being in Toronto
would have scared me with Manziel too so
that but yeah that's the first thing I
thought of oh gosh we're gonna put him a
city with a very good social scene and I
know they're professionals are partying
up there and we're gonna put him there
on a crappy team so we'll see this is
gonna be big really because he's gonna
get his chance to play now there's no
doubt about that I mean that mantra at
Alouettes team I read some of the
quarterbacks on
roster I mean they're they're not
anywhere in Johnny manziel's caliber
right and we're gonna see what he's got
now as a player because I would imagine
here in the next few weeks the next week
or two cuz I think it's it's gonna be
Mike Sherman basic West Coast offense
it's gonna be similar to his of course
Texas A&M offense it's gonna be similar
to even what Kyle Shanahan as far as
verbage random of the Cleveland Browns
yeah so I wouldn't think it's gonna take
him long to catch up man highlights man
cell man so alright got two little
Facebook question Rogers here fan
questions Josh is in the back looking
like Dick Cheney
this one's from Ben Lesh Appel 3 I do
the Patriots have hundreds of plays such
as maybe trick plays that they have
practiced and have down they have never
used they know will catch the defense
off guard
such as the Julian Edelman trick play
where he passed two Amendola for a
touchdown against the Ravens on the
playoffs they have they have thousands
of plays but yes they are a team that
will practice trick plays from time to
time certainly throughout the year to go
this is like we've practiced the you
know they'll they'll practice it and
it'll be invented in week one but they
might not run it till week 12 and then
every week like one time a week they go
let's run our trick play so yes they
have things in the inventory and it can
go from there to well they'll just add
it during the seizure and they'll pull
it out when they think it's just do
other teams have that too I think a lot
not all no I think there's a few teams
that do that like wood pride themselves
like Gruden we always had a trick player
to I mean we would practice them to
every week maybe twice a week he would
never call a trick play I mean we never
called the trick play when I was there I
don't think five years now one time no I
flea-flicker reverse pass because he
didn't want to put the hands oh just my
offense my plays I'll do the job we
don't need any tricks here or whatever
and New England's like that way for the
most part true this is where I think New
England's brilliant they only bring it
out in the games where they go yeah we
need it
Baltimore's better than us we gotta have
a like a trick play to get us over the
edge
every big game I bet you could find one
one trick play in every big game the
Patriots play look if Tom Brady caught
that pass and the Super Bowl
Brady had nothing but open fields in
front it's a Parcells thing right so
this the Parcells is really was the guy
that always had a trick play ready and
if you really think about bow Parcells
Bill Parcells were in a punt formation
quarterback sneak and the Super Bowl my
dad won right they were losing 10 to 9
they got the ball to start the second
half they got down third and third in
like inches yeah or no yeah fourth and
inches sorry they brought the punt team
out he put in the backup quarterback and
they ran a quarterback sneak that was
them and then they went down score the
touchdown the game was never the same
that was Bill Parcells in 1990 they go
to San Francisco and beat the three-peat
49ers they did a fake punt in that game
right up the middle to Garry reasons as
anybody will remember it was third I
mean fourth and long they snapped it up
the middle to Garry reasons they're
starting middle linebacker who was like
the punt protector hmm and he ran up the
middle for a huge first down so that is
a Parcells tree to have things like that
40 moments Sean Payton Parcells coaching
tree onside kick to start the second
half of the Super Bowl it's part of
their but he was so amazing about Doug
is is for Nick Foles to come to the
sidelines and say Philly Philly yeah and
then Doug go yeah he matched his
Kahuna's Belichick in that game you have
to have to his right number one thing we
always get frustrated about playoff
teams it's like that's why to be honest
guys we get frustrated Blake bortles in
the Jaguars we used to get it frustrated
like that with the Seattle Seahawks if
you remember back in the day because
we'd go it's Seattle is a great quarter
they keep the [ __ ] out of this team for
three quarters and it's 1714 they're
winning and they should be winning 34 to
14 yeah you know because they played it
close to the vest but that's what
Jackson when you when you know you're
better you don't want to do too many
crazy things I know but when you're
better it's like when you're playing
poker if you have the most chips be a
bully
yeah like get a little risky right
people are gonna assume they're gonna
want to back away from you I hear you
but yeah Jacksonville better come out
net Nathanael Hackett better come up
some cool ash it'll be a big year for
him all right one more see Rob 60 my
boss is convinced that more than half
the NFL is on steroids he listed Peyton
and a and ap as guys who for sure
haven't but
said julian edelman for sure didn't New
England fan I need you in Sims to set
him straight
alright well I mean you know first of
all I think Julian on one did I'm just
gonna say that I don't mean to disagree
with our friend their boss but it's it's
hard for me but to say half the NFL I
just I couldn't disagree more now like I
have this argument with some people that
they think there's like maybe 20 to 25
20 guys on the team that maybe do it I
don't see it that way I think maybe you
have two two three maybe four guys in a
locker room that are probably holding
the line of cheating and somehow someway
but I just been around too many freaks
of nature whether it's I'm not even
gonna listening but all they do is eat
fast food smoke weed and drink liquor at
all they do is get faster and shrug I
know they're not cheating and if they
are cheating then they're screwing
themselves with the other poison and
they're putting it in their body anyways
so III don't see it that way again
gonna go back to an old Sims and left go
phrase if you saw some of these guys
mothers you wouldn't think they were on
performance-enhancing drugs and I mean
that in the most respectful way my dad's
mother could have played middle
linebacker in the NFL Barbara had man
hands square shoulders bigger than left
Co and she could have squared you up and
whooped your ass most of you out there
okay so same thing with a lot of these I
mean we laugh about it at the draft
every year and I know Josh he gets all
scared them and say something but we
always take notice and go it damn those
parents look how [ __ ] big they are
yeah I didn't owe to far there let's see
josh is looking at NIMH is a grin leg I
don't know if that's gonna make the cut
but at least I use my own grandmother
this time it was good good Barbara
Barbara your telling you and me both
have a caramel Barbara yeah Barbara is
yeah six-foot I mean my Barbara was 510
we used to rip chickens heads off when
their hands I'm telling you that yeah
she's famous for those stories in our
household give me a little bit because
like she was a farmhand and she's like I
said she's she's ruthless like she would
just tell it to you how the way there's
now Christopher when I was your age I
mean I was already ripping chickens
heads off like what but yeah she could
like she is famous for she would get the
chicken and she could rip his head
off with his/her two hands and then she
tell the story how the chicken would run
around without a head for like 30
seconds good old farm times in Kentucky
hell yeah man she's passed away she has
passed away damn it's the only dead
person my kids have seen and they were
in so intrigued by that what yeah like
we went to her funeral and we did an
open casket and like my kids literally
like ran in there to see her dead god
rest her soul she's the woman so and I
know some people gonna cry you're
insensitive no I'm keeping her memory
alive by talking about it I don't look
at it ran in there they ran there like I
was like okay guys cuz I can warn them
like there's I think it's gonna be an
open casket see grandma my grandma here
she's not gonna be alive she's gonna be
you know whatever and they I mean
sprinted like the rest of the family
there hey hey you don't know they just
kept running because they wanted to see
I ever tell you my Kentucky open casket
story yeah oh my god
all right this is really late so I was I
would frequent this one bar and they had
like a deejay guy there and we would
come in and and man I can't I came over
his name so we would casually talk and
that'd be it and one day I'm on my day
off it's a when's taking with it I told
you this yet and I get a phone call and
it goes hi is this Adam and I said yes
they go I'm so sorry to tell you but
Lance has passed away and I'm sitting
there going she was so sad I was like oh
my gosh like I'm so sorry like who are
you all I'm lances a.m. oh I I didn't
realize she goes I didn't realize you
guys were friends I was like yeah I said
what was lands doing like I'm just
trying to figure it out I realized it's
this DJ and I was like oh okay and she
was like listen the funeral is gonna be
by the law I would I know it means so
much to him if you came all and my
friend Tiffany got invited to because
she would go this bar with me so this
night we you know we get dressed in our
clothes and she goes I can't believe
we're doing this like I was like I know
like I don't know anybody like I barely
know this guy but like they called me I
have to go like let's go we go in there
and there's like a huge line of people
and we walk up
and we're getting closer to kind of pay
our respects to open casket and before I
can even see thing I hear Adam left Co
whas 11 News is that you and I look and
like these two guys come over there like
I watch you on TV all the time man how
you doing and I was like hey yeah sorry
about Lance man but anyway what do think
about Rick patina and we said that
starts happening I look and I realize
like there's a semicircle forming around
me and people are leaving the open
casket to come and talk to me about Rick
Pitino
John Calipari right and I was like okay
guys like I want to go pay my respects
and I go and I look and Lance has a
little mustache and he never had a
mustache in his hair slicked back and I
guess the the person that prepares the
body put that on there and I'm looking
at Tiffany and I was like damn this and
that doesn't that looks weirdly he looks
weird and this woman comes to us Oh Adam
you made it and I was like this must be
the ant on the phone I was like hi how
are you and she hugs me and then her
friend it's like other woman's like and
puts out her arms to hug me and I was
like okay and she hugged me and was like
rubbing my back for like way too long
and Tiffany's look at me like what is
going on right now and she's of there
Adams no they knew who I was they were
like Adam left go like oh my god how are
you and I was like great and there was
this moment of silence like like this
little brief pause and I go how about a
Lance's mustache and they go he didn't
understand why they did that like we
don't know why they put a mustache on
him and I said all I know is it's so
Lance and they they stop and they go
that is so Lance and like like clapping
and laughing like you don't land so well
and Tiffany's look at me like that's so
Lance like are you [ __ ] kidding me
and I was like yeah yeah like so it's
already crazy I go over and I kneeled
down next to the mother mm-hmm she has
been weeping she has been bawling she's
sitting there over her son he was like
in his 20s and I kneeled down next to
her and I say ma'am I just want to let
you know that you had an amazing son he
was a great person he was a good friend
of mine and I want to give you my
condolences I'm so sorry for your loss
and she's crying and she looks down at
me and she does a double take and I
where to God she goes animal f-code whas
11 News you do sports I watch you every
night and I was like ha hi ma'am how are
you and she goes this is such a sudden
surprise and then she looks up my friend
Tiffany was talking she she brushes her
hand away he looks back at me she goes
we have a costume contest coming up for
the Halloween in like three weeks
Lance was supposed to tell you about it
he must have forgotten is there any way
that you can do that and I'm sitting
there like did you just blame your son
for forgetting to ask me and I said I I
would be happy to I would happen to be a
judge for hard to turn that one day he
goes oh my god this is so great talking
about guilt and I was like all right and
she goes so good to meet you and I was
like you too ma'am and literally I get
up and Tiffany goes costume contest and
immediately I hear the mom now crying
like she's back to it and we go outside
and I was just I'm blown away I've never
experienced anything like that but uh
yeah I got asked to do the costume
contest that was my Kentucky open casket
people are weird it was pretty
incredible it was one of my finer
moments here but I never got called for
the costume contest I think it got
canceled like yeah that's assumes left
go back to death stories end of the week
that's how we put them away right in the
ground all right on Wednesday we will be
having David Baker from the NFL Hall of
Fame I got a lot of questions to talk to
them yeah I got a lot of questions about
tea oh it's a very interesting year for
what they got going on we are also going
to hopefully have on Phil Simms and it
will be the official whoa big offseason
awards show me and fence you're going to
get together right now we're gonna have
all the categories we're gonna kind of
figure it out from the whoa big
offseason MVP to the whoa of the
offseason got a lot of stuff to get
through so the whoa big offseason Awards
will be on Wednesday are you excited
very bring your tux Brett I will okay
yep okay for Sims peace out homies for
federic good evening and for the lef
kale
man we would say good evening an
afternoon I'm good night love you guys
so much we'll see on Wednesday thank you
guys for being with us
props to meatloaf in the SL FL follow us
on social at Sims and left go and he
does a mother I think we set a record
for longest pot guys everybody